[Musique]
à l'occasion de la journée mondiale
contre le gaspillage alimentaire ce
mercredi 16 octobre une centaine
d'acteurs du secteur se sont réunis
nouveaux cas pour le lancement du régal
réunion porté par la scop rd2 à la
charte du réseau pour éviter le
gaspillage alimentaire a été signé par
les financeurs et partenaires à
l'initiative de ce projet les galeries
nyon alors un régal c'est un réseau pour
éviter le gaspillage alimentaire est
donc aujourd'hui c'est octobre 2019
à l'occasion de la journée nationale de
lutte contre le gaspillage alimentaire
la réunion lance son propre régal c'est
donc un réseau par et pour les acteurs
pour réfléchir et agir ensemble pour
promouvoir le bien manger pour soi et
pour la planète sur notre territoire
le département a été un partenaire
opérationnel de premier plan et tous les
pc de lille
sont membres actifs des groupes de
travail effectivement le département est
un partenaire incontournable de cette
charte ou plusieurs actions au sein du
département à travers les collèges
on n'a pas perdu de temps on a depuis
quelques années mais un dispositif
le dispositif ne gaspille ou quinze
collèges du département participent à la
lutte pour le gaspillage et ses collèges
sont des collèges effectivement inspiré
mentale et ça permet aussi à
sensibiliser et éduquer les enfants à
pouvoir effectivement en amont pouvoir
lutter pour le gaspillage aller à
l'occasion de ce lancement était mise en
place divers ateliers présentant des
actions inspirant pour lutter contre le
gaspillage alimentaire un vivier de
bonnes pratiques et le régal réunion
sont valorisés alors aujourd'hui on est
venu présenter les invente comment
retravailler sur les invendus la
spéciale mans si les fruits et légumes
on a pu récupérer ses jamar chaud pour
pouvoir distribuer des jus de fruits
frais j'en ai partie d'un concert ces
concepts autour de iasi
aujourd'hui enfin voilà fait partie du
secteur de la boulangerie
on s'est rendu compte qu'on avait
beaucoup de pertes sur certains produits
aujourd'hui les plus gros taux de perte
sont le pain au chocolat et le croissant
à ça on a doublé plusieurs alternatives
par exemple
pour le moment sans four et donc ça
c'est bien un croissant de la veille on
fabrique pas des croisements pour faire
des croissants fourrés
c'est pour ça que nous entendons devenir
des clients peut-être un petit peu déçu
c'est à dire que si on a pas de
croissance verte 1 la veille pour
trouvera pas de croissants fourrés sont
dans nos vitrines long autre alternative
on s'est rendu compte que le prince son
coup c'est vraiment le un peu le jeu
quand j'étais assez régulièrement depuis
plusieurs années maintenant on les
travaille on retravaille le lendemain
compte encore une fois on ne fabrique
pas des produits pour faire des teintes
chocolat amandes c'est vraiment
fonctionné ce qu'ils à rester là bas on
a mis en place donc par l'intermédiaire
de de niro note donc en application qui
s'appelle aux barquettes donc pour
mettre en place donc une traçabilité
pour la valorisation des excédents
alimentaires de production de la
restauration scolaire au profit de la
solidarité collective comme notamment
pour l'aide alimentaire pour la
croix-rouge ou pour l'organisation de
repas solidaire une lutte contre le
gaspillage alimentaire en vue
d'atteindre moins 50% de gaspillage
d'ici 2025
[Musique]